Just talking
about Congress
preparing to act
to avert this rail shutdown.
President Biden warning
if that happened,
it would devastate the economy
if we had a strike like that.
So joining me now
to talk about this
and a lot more is Bank of Americ
Brian Moynihan, chairman and CEO
one of the biggest banks in the
You know where the economy is he
We'll get into all of it.
We really appreciate
you coming in to CNN this mornin
First of all, congratulations
on the new show to you
and your colleagues.
You said
look at
things like the rail strike or t
in Ukraine.
And, you know,
what happens in China was shut d
Those are all sort of things
that can really derail the econo
And everybody knows that.
And we've been dealing with them
for quite a period of time.
But if you look at the core econ
our team has
a mild recession,
predicted the middle of 20, 23
and then coming back out of it
later in 20, 23.
Now that was predicted to happen
this year, earlier this year.
The there
was going to be a real slow down
The Fed is going to raise rates
and it's all pushed out largely
because of one thing which is th
consumer who is spending money.
And we just got our
spending from Thanksgiving
to last Saturday
and it was up 3% over last year
which is up 23% of the year befo
20% over where it was 19.
You see
booking travel and things like t
you see the consumers employed.
You see them
spending money,
you see not having money in acco
now that means inflation
has to be tackled by the Fed.
But the consumer actually
is both a buffer against that
and also makes it difficult.
What I think so
interesting about you, Brian,
is you've been like the,
you know, the optimist in all of
So you just said,
yes, a mild recession next year,
but we'll get through it
by the following year.
Jamie Dimon
warned this summer ahead of JPMo
that an economic hurricane
his words are coming.
We just don't know
how strong a hurricane.
Do you see an economic hurricane
Well, the hurricane season is no
So having a house in the Carolin
I used to deal with that.
But, you know, at the end of the
the belief was
if any of those horribles came t
you could have really a differen
than the Fed tightening.
And the Fed is tightening in
an unprecedented way
because we have an unprecedented
inflation. 40, 50 year long infl
So when does that affect first h
Obviously, that's changed dramat
but rent
increases are only coming throug
So in the end of the day,
the consumer is held in well
and the consumer stays reasonabl
because they're employed.
So I'm hearing no economic
hurricane from Brian Moynihan.
Right. A mild recession.
A mild recession. Okay.
So let's tick through all those
Housing matters, everyone.
It is
much more expensive to buy a hou
because of mortgage rates.
And your own research
of Bank of America shows
how much rents have increased.
So people feel like they're out
When is it going to get better
for housing for Americans?
Well,
so this is the toughest thing
because you have to slow down
the economy.
You have to slow down
inflation in a way you do.
That's raising interest rates.
Fed wants us to buy fewer homes.
That's exactly right.
And so what is the intended
outcome of their policies?
Doesn't feel good
when you're trying to buy a home
if you're young family
trying to buy your first home, w
So that'll straighten out, thoug
You have to sort housing the two
One is the people who have mortg
that are outstanding
locked in below 5%, 4%, 3%, 90%
below five,
80% below for 50% below three.
They're locked in for 30 years o
other folks.
But when you go to buy a house,
you're feeling that effect.
And that's slowed down dramatica
And that's
why the homebuilders and others.
But that's the intended outcome.
What will happen is as we see
inflation slow down
and you're seeing the rate of gr
inflation slow down, stop inflat
you'll see rates come back down
to the more the target rate
and you'll see
the adjustments come through
and that'll happen.
That'll take almost two years,
two years of pain for people
trying to rent or buy a house,
two years of solar activity.
Now the rental side of that is t
and that's the rents are increas
and you're seeing
rents have increased
and already starting to decrease
in some town cities around the c
But that's
where you have to be more concer
because half the people in Ameri
pay rent. They don't on their ho
And that is where it's effect.
That's still ahead of us.
And millions of them
have a lot of outstanding
credit card debt.
And can you just help us underst
why credit card
interest rates are at a record h
I understand the Fed's raising r
but the Fed funds target
rate compared to April seems ext
And I know there's not collatera
to back credit cards, but like,
do they really need to be that h
Well,
the reality is
a third of our credit cards
pay off every month.
They don't even pay interest rat
So we give you the money
for 30 days later.
45 days later, you pay us.
Three thirds of Americans don't.
And then the ones that do it,
the rate
structure's far
lower than the standard rate str
just because of
all the different things have go
So let
those rates adjust with the mark
They'll come back down with the
They were low for a long time.
But the reality is, is
that the good
news is for
America is the delinquencies
on credit cards are low.
They are much lower.
They were 19,
which is very good
credit times for banking system.
So our job is to actually help
our customers continue
to prosper and live.
And the key thing is,
remember, unemployment's at 3.6.
The three
the worst projections are get th
we're where it was in the 1718 r
You met with President Biden,
I think it was in
July at the White House.
I wonder how you
presidents get a lot of credit
when the economy does well
and all the blame when it does p
How do you think he's handling
this economy?
Well,
and then to date, he's dealing
with very unprecedented times.
So, you know,
the job of the American people
to decide that
and they just had election.
What do you
what does Brian Moynihan think?
I think our economy is holding
on better
than the rest of the world right
Okay.
Now, the reality is, is
did we give more stimulus than,
you could theoretically calculat
but nobody knew at the time.
Too much stimulus. Lesson learne
But that was to test
administration as administration
but nobody knew at the time.
And I think that's where people
look through the rearview mirror
and always have a great point of
The sportswriters can,
but the players on the field
had to make a decision
was that right or not? And they
Now we have to adjust to that de
That's where you're seeing the F
tighten.
Quick, I want to talk about
what's going on with workers.
You have you employ
so many people at Bank of Americ
you've also taken
you have lead on wages,
increasing wages now to $22 an h
At the bottom,
you're going to be $25 an hour b
But real wages are down for folk
because of inflation
and something is going on with w
I was home in Minnesota this wee
Coffee shops were closed.
They couldn't find workers, rest
can't find enough workers.
We're seeing unionization
at companies that never saw it b
Starbucks, Amazon,
news outlets like BuzzFeed.
What is happening
with the American worker well, t
the labor markets got very tight
So the dynamics shifted that
with the kind of employment leve
we had.
You know, the claims for unemplo
still are bumping along
at very low levels, levels
that haven't been seen since.
The numbers of workers are like
25% lower.
So, you know,
the labor market is very tight
in some negotiation.
Power moves around, right?
I mean, that's what happens.
The quit rates got way high.
What you're seeing that now is m
which is actually good
from the Fed perspective
in terms of economy.
But you're seeing that mitigate
How do we think about that?
Our job is to provide an ability
for an 18 year old to join our c
and get here their entire career
get themselves
educated and trained with us.
And you do that all day.
I just celebrated the 50 55,
60, 65 and a 75 year
employee the other day.
So think of 75, do some math
and think that the person start
and went to college.
That's what great employers do.
And so our turnover rate moved u
like everybody else has
already moved back down.
My guess is by early next year
you'll be back
in line was 19 which is good
but that takes employers really
how do I holistically help
a person develop
like you guys gave money
a lot of it
to employees to pay for childcar
during the pandemic
when you ask them to come back.
I want to talk about China
you do a fair
amount of business in China.
How worried are you about
what we're seeing on the streets
and Xi Jinping's tight
grasp on power and zero COVID?
I think
the thing we have to think about
is they're
they're still dealing with COVID
the way we're dealing with it
in 2020 in the spring,
which is your choice to shut dow
And that is very disruptive.
The supply chain, the internal e
We've dropped our projections
in the company down to 3% GDP gr
Our economy generally always gre
five to six.
So it's affecting our economy.
It's affecting the worldwide eco
The shortages
we Don talked about, you know,
the railroads are not having sho
if we don't have the goods we ca
And that
that supply chain is still not e
and that
that is somewhat good news
and that that stuff still is bou
and has to get through the syste
But it's bad news because,
you know, slow people's purchasi
because they don't think
they can get something.
And that's
that's kind of the issue in Chin
So leave aside the
you know,
the health care struggle
and the human struggle,
which is horrible.
But the reality is from
an economic perspective,
they're shutting down,
is causing a world disruption.
And they really don't have a cho
it seems,
because they don't
have the structure
that we have nine states
with vaccines
and people through the system
so you're concerned about.
We're always concerned about Twi
Bank of America
is one of the big banks
that financed Elon Musk's
takeover of Twitter.
Elon Musk himself
tweeted a few weeks ago,
Twitter could go bankrupt.
You're hanging on to a lot of th
The Financial Times is
reporting you guys,
the big banks are waiting
for a business plan from Musk.
Here's
what it's
going to look like to unload tha
Have you gotten the business pla
What do you make of how he's lea
Well,
that's
not something
that we talk about with clients.
I mean, I don't I don't
and by the way, I'm
the worst person
to be in the middle of a credit
because that's not what I do
in the company.
But if you look at it
just on leveraged
finance, which is people
talk about the way we market the
every Friday,
you know,
so it's all through the panel
and whatever impacts and, you kn
he'll run the company the way he
He owns it.
They have tremendous equity in i
And so we'll see what happens.
Hoping for the best.
We don't hope we plan for the bo
I do want to ask you about crypt
You have been very cautious
always on cryptocurrency.
Look what has happened.
Look at EFT collapsing.
Look at this week.
BlockFi, which is a crypto lende
that I think it's important peop
now lend to.
It was for average folks.
This is for the main street
average Joe collapsing.
What went wrong with crypto?
I.
What went wrong is I think it wa
your perspective asset got very
and then came crashing down
and the leverage embedded.
No, all that happened
but that was relatively predicta
and many of us said be cautious
The good news is
if you think about the history o
the rate of movement out of our
into crypto
slowed way down
which means investors have
to be more cautious at least.
And you guys are so highly regul
I mean, watch any of those, you
testimony before Congress or so.
And like
where are the regulators on this
Is it safe
for anyone
to have a crypto market
that exists anymore without regu
But if you
have to back up two things
blockchain technology very good.
We have hundreds of patents on i
Literally,
the idea of the current,
the idea of a currency and stuff
it's not needed.
We can transact in ways
that are wonderfully fast
and real payments system
that are connecting around the w
the Fed is building on.
We've already built one in the i
you know, the ability
to send money to anywhere
in the banking system, you know,
these things are important.
So are the areas
where the industry has to lead
and that
other entrepreneurs saw an oppor
Yes, the small balance, you know
a cross-border payment.
And we're working on
stuff to make that easier.